reina fautes dont on va beaucoup parler
je pense dans les prochains jours c'est
un député qui a révélé que brigitte
macro avait pris une position très ferme
et courageuse sur un sujet de société
je vous laisse découvrir la vidéo son
mari n'est pas d'accord donc ça va faire
débat en tout cas ça va débat qui va
faire certainement débat en parlant son
poste avant ça va faire du ramdam
mcqueen ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
ça va faire débat selon le nouvel obs
brigitte macron serait totalement pour
la légalisation du cannabis à des fins
thérapeutiques en france une
réglementation qui est déjà en vigueur
dans de nombreux pays comme l'allemagne
l'espagne l'italie la belgique ou encore
le royaume uni mais même si la france
est le premier consommateur de cannabis
en europe les choses ne sont pas
forcément prêt de changer car il ya un
problème de taille
emmanuel macron de son côté serait
beaucoup moins ouvert à cette
légalisation que sa femme alors
arrivera-t-elle à le convaincre
affaire à suivre alors c'est vrai dans
ces frappes
alors quelqu'un pour ici la vérité
thérapeutique oui oui oui non mais oui
d'emblée non parce que la thérapeutique
non pas thérapeutique je vous dis ça va
être l'égalisation pas l'égalisation
donc faut arrêter de jouer sur les mots
sans pareil dans les pays européens tous
les paysans de l'engagement a été
autorisé oui mais bon vous mêmes ce
premier pas vers le premier rang pour le
thérapeutique ne sais pas c'est pas là
du cannabis qu'on va fumer un ya pas de
suresnes sort de deux pétards qu'on va
fumer donc moi je trouve au contraire
coinchée contre mais vous êtes vraiment
un chien non je vous donne ma vraie
position parce que j'ai vu des gens qui
ont énormément souffert de la drogue et
pour moi ce serait le premier pas vers
et donc je ne veux pas que ce premier
pas eh oui mais je vous donne accès pour
soigner les gens mais bon voilà
non pour moi voilà c'est pour ça que
c'est en cristallisé en france à grenard
mai dernier mais c'est pour soulager des
gens qui au détriment très lourd
forcément et voilà c'est à voir mais bon
si vous êtes content et peut être contre
les cellules
lomé - si vous êtes contre je suis
clairement contre personne en tous les
cas on connaît pas le cerveau de chacun
et on sait pas comment il va réagir
faire prendre les cannabis aux gens et
c'est des gens qui souffrent déjà au
depor toutefois déjà que c'est pas pour
les rendre dingue non plus cyril c'est
pas la raison la raison j'aurais qui au
moins trois ordonnances croisés parce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est pareil pour
la codéine et tout cas voir une
ordonnance pour un produit interdit
malheureusement c'est extrêmement facile
par un médecin un cousin un nombre et
c'est une ordonnance
il renvoie c'est très facile à n'importe
qui beaucoup de filles honneur de nous
faire un petit pour un pote pour un
cousin et tu vas de l'acheter il est là
le problème c'est la dérive c'est comme
ça qu'on a interdit la colline du
codéine aujourd'hui pour les gamins sur
les dérives c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait
au moins trois ordonnances coordoner
dites nous si vous n'êtes pas au
concours dire je vois la voilà la
réaction des téléspectateurs
ce serait pas en pharmacie bonjour
monsieur je mens cannabis thérapeutique
s'évaderait à l'hôpital avec tout un
protocole de médecins ou éventuellement
l'aï dit sur ordonnance un pardon
ordonnance pour des grands malades pour
nous oui mais oui sur ordonnance il peut
avoir des dérives il ay là il a ses
raisons sur sa gestion du match juste
pour voir tout ça à cause de ça ça
arrive oui oui je bernamont normes et
des vertus c'est à des vertus que
reconnus par les grands scientifiques
alors juste vous lorsque nous la
question tourne the moon vous êtes vous
êtes vous est pote avec eux brigitte pas
qu'on est ce que vous en a parlé de ça
ça du tout pas du tout va vous parle que
de iv sincèrement pas du tout bon mais
simplement dire que les causes de
mortalité sont plus importantes avec le
tabac et l'alcool
bagis a ses vertus sont reconnues
je vous précise que c'est du cannabis
ont substance si ça vient d'un ex toile
alors on va voir le sondage s'il vous
plaît parce que le sondage a été fait
pour à 78% qu'on la balle à 75,26 rip